voici comment optimiser la batterie sur
votre smartphone Samsung c'est très
malin c'est simple vous avez pas grand
chose à faire vous venez ici dans vos
paramètres et dans vos paramètres vous
allez sur batterie et maintenant de
l'appareil pour le faire manuellement en
cliquant sur optimiser maintenant ça va
venir mouliner c'est simple c'est
pratique c'est rapide ok on peut faire
beaucoup mieux puisque vous allez sur
l'optimisation automatique là il vous
marque l'application maintenant de
l'appareil effectue automatiquement les
optimisations pour permettre à votre
téléphone de fonctionner de manière
fluide cela inclut la fermeture des
applications en arrière-plan et le
nettoyage de la mémoire donc vous voulez
vraiment l'activer comme ça vous serez
peinard votre smartphone fait le job
tout seul et ça c'est très chouette
est-ce que vous connaissez cette astuce
marquez le moi dans les commentaires